oh
just a piece of ice
crystal of ice is just floating
oh and a fish
don't be scared little fish
we might get a really cool tour
of
tube a tube down the ice to get to see
what's underneath all participants must
have current outdoor safety lecture
check
all participants have appropriate ecw
and a pee bottle if needed check
so this is neil
who wants to be first oh that's pretty
deep why is being tall harder because
you can't bend your arms and legs
lid you'll see a little bit better down
there
thanks
wow
we are
below the ice
surface why am i talking like this
wow
that is amazing
wow
just
crazy
it has this impression of
infinity that's just
really awesome
we are 10 meters
below the surface of the ice
so you can see above me
all of these ice crystals
which is the bottom of the ice there's a
little fish right here
almost transparent
and the people who were here before us
said that every now and then there's a
seal and plays a visit
you can also see these really
thick
structures so the
ice has got to be like
four or five meters thick i think it
could stay hours here
this was unbelievable
i didn't get to see a seal although
there's a seal over there
lounging and every now and then you can
hear them
communicating let's see how well this
ice slides
because i'm a bit strange like that is
this
i'm speculating that that might be his
thumbprint yeah well if he managed to
get it in the ink as he was writing that
that could easily be so this is
observation hill which is a landmark you
can see behind oh okay a whole bunch of
uh sleeping penguins there i imagine uh
yes you could put it that way yeah